- Been testing resistance
at 32 for a while now.
(distant car horns beeping)
(clicks)
False break.
Wait, no.
(inspiring orchestral music)
RSI's at 30.
Tight build up.
30 to 32.
No way.
(paper rustling)
(marker squeaks)
Holy shit.
It's coming.
(orchestral music intensifies)
(music fades away)
I'm 29, I used to be an
equities trader at Citadel,
when I used work in TradFi.
I used to be a math major at Princeton,
olympiad medalist,
and now I trade crypto full time.
(heavy bass music)
Wagwan people, I'm 19 years old,
and I trade cryptos and
NFTs full time, baby.
(laughing)
You probably know me as
KryptoPapi on TikTok,
where I bless you pagans
with masterclasses,
free of charge.
These are my top five coins...
(overlapping chatter)
(shuffling sounds)
When you're balling like this,
you have to share it you get me?
Yeah, I do yield-farming
on Eth and Solana,
so, providing liquidity
for stablecoin pools
on Curve and Solend.
Basically borrowing from
one lending protocol
and then lending it at
another lending protocol
with a higher APY to maximize my yield.
(phone dings)
Essentially...
essentially it's just
basic interest arbitrage
Just a minute.
- [KryptoPapi From Phone]
You trynna ball like this?
Shiba. Nah.
Dogecoin. Nah.
Safemoon... (laughs) is
mooning. Safely. (laughs)
Shee!
(computer keys tapping)
- [Interveiwer] And what
is your trading strategy?
- Ooh ooh ooh. Ooh ooh ooh.
(monkey noises intensify)
(shouting)
Yes, yes! Yes!
Cut.
- I don't really share my net-worth,
but let's just say when
I worked at Citadel
yearly bonuses can range from
$300,000 to seven figures.
I've been there for like 6 years now,
but I trade crypto full-time now.
And I mean I do have my
down days from time to time,
but I make about 30 to
40% yearly on crypto, so
you can kind of deduce
my net-worth like that.
- Ten million. No, wait.
It's got to be at least 13 million.
But who can really say,
the US dollar is on a
mad one of these days,
You get me?
- Wait, sorry, who else
are you talking to?
KryptoPapi?
Are you serious?
(laughs incredulously)
Dude, he's my mentor!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, let me call him right now.
Oh shit.
Fucking phone.
Dude, this is such a
coincidence, it's crazy.
- What's good, YG?
- Ayo, yo yo, what is up? (giggles)
Yo, are you doing this interview, too?
- No way, you in there as well?
No cap, yeah?
- Wait, sorry, what does that mean?
Like, cap as in marker cap?
Or cap as in, like, limit?
- Hold on, big man, I
just remembered something.
(ominous music)
I just got a message from a little birdie.
There's gonna be some
serious action on New IDO.
You good for a little pump and dump, yeah?
- So which coin are we flipping this time?
- Now you didn't hear this from me,
but the buzz is on Blindrcoin.
- Hey, yeah.
Is this the IRS?
Okay, cool.
Uh, yeah, I have it, I have it.
Um, so on the fifteenth,
I bought some Simp coins.
Yeah, 20,000 of them.
Yeah, which I used as a collateral
to borrow 10,000 of Cumrocket. C-U-M.
Which I leverage yield-farmed
with the Shitcoins
to buy some Solanaslut NFTs...
Hello? Hello?
Shit.
Every fucking time. (sighs)
(paper flipping)
Hope you enjoyed that video!
In case you don't know, I
am starting an NFT project
to fund my video production
so that I can make
videos without sponsors,
because some of them do
limit my creative freedom.
It's called Vaxxed Doggos.
There's 2,500 of them.
They're all unique,
and I drew on every single one of them.
Crazy thing,
we did a special auction
for Lunar New Year,
and we got 69.69 Sol for this auction,
which is amazing,
which means my community
is quite juvenile,
but it also means we
were able to raise $6,350
to a non-profit organization called
Asians Fighting Injustice.
So thank you, Ventex1000,
who won the auction,
you are helping a great cause.
But yeah, follow Vaxxed Doggos on Twitter,
and join the discord to learn more,
and also to learn how to
support me as a creator.
Also, I wanted to give a
special thanks to Current,
who was kind enough to
let us use their amazing
space for filming.
They are also growing super fast,
so if you're an engineer
and looking for a job,
Current is an amazing place to work at,
with amazing people.
I have a link to their job board,
so apply if you're looking.
Peace!
(ominous music)